bastia bruit venait pas n'importe quelle
installation militaire car c'est
l'endroit où depuis huit ans déjà sont
organisées les missions d'entraînement
des soldats ukrainiens par les forces
des etats-unis du canada du royaume uni
et d'autres partenaires occidentaux de
l'ukraine donc c'est le lieu symbolique
de l'assistance militaire de l'ukraine
par ses alliés à l'ouest depuis depuis
huit ans déjà depuis le début de la
guerre dont le dôme base pour le moment
on ignore s'il y avait des conseillers
ou des étrangers ou des
ou des entraîneurs étrangers sur la base
au moment de l' attaque mais on sait que
c'était une attaque assez massive les
roquettes ont été tirées par des avions
que le gouverneur de la région a dit
qu'il ne savait pas si ces avions
volaient dans l'espace aérienne
l'ukrainien ou bien s'il était au dessus
par exemple de la biélorussie ou de la
mer noire et qu'ils ont tiré depuis
là-bas de longues distances il a dit
qu'il y à 23 impacts que les autorités
ukrainiennes sont en train
d'examiner en ce moment